foreign
in the course of a single morning in a
dizzying period of about three hours
Peru experienced an attempted coup
d'etat the arrest of its president and
the swearing end of a successor to
re-establish constitutional order it was
perhaps the shortest and worst executed
coup attempt of all time however this
whole story goes far beyond Pedro
Castile because in reality this is the
story of Peru's political decline a
story of hatred confrontation disloyalty
and the ambition for power let's get
cracking
[Music]
what pushed former president Pedro
Castillo to carry out such an active
institutional subversion was he really
able to dissolve Congress why did his
attempt fail and perhaps the most
important question of all what exactly
is going on with Peruvian politics that
is going from bad to worse is Castile
the only one to blame well there's your
politic viewers in this video we're
going to answer all of these questions
but first we need to establish a few
things Pedro Castile a humble rural
school teacher from one of the poorest
areas of Peru with a strong
anti-establishment discourse and no
political or management expertise was
sworn in as president on 28th of July
2021.
foreign
however he barely held the presidency
for 495 full days that is less than a
year and a half
[Music]
in the 2021 presidential elections
Castillo went to the second round with
just 18.9 of the vote and managed to win
by a slim margin of just over 40 000 out
of the nearly 19 million votes cast he
won thanks to a runoff against Kiku
fujimori the daughter of the imprisoned
former president Alberto fujimori who
was rejected by half the country be that
as it may it seemed clear from the
beginning that despite his Grand
promises Castillo was going to have a
very very difficult time he is a
president who took office with a very
low level of support he did not have a
political party he had a hard time
putting together a cabinet the cabinet
has changed constantly and there has
been a constant power struggle with
Congress Flavia freidenberg political
scientist at the national autonomous
University of Mexico without political
experience without a clear plan and
faced with a head-on rejection by the
Parliament that little more than 16
months that Castile was at the Helm of
the country where a disaster and only
495 days this president had five
governments and 78 different ministers
appointments were made practically every
week only one person Roberto Sanchez
minister of foreign trade and tourism
managed to remain in office during all
of that time others were dismissed or
resigned amid scandals and
misunderstandings of all kinds some
portfolios as important and Peruvian
Politics as the ministry of the interior
of the Ministry of Agriculture have seen
seven and six ministers respectively
remember that this was in less than a
year and a half it's total Madness Pedro
Castile changed government more times
than he changed socks
[Music]
obviously with so much back and forth in
practice any government action was
impossible and that's not all on top of
this shift in context we have to add to
Congress that decided to make his life
impossible the incompetence and lack of
planning in a president who is
alternating between Marxist and
conservative supporters and as if that
were not enough a bunch of corruption
investigations that mired him even
further in fact in October 2022 we find
this news check this out the Peruvian
public prosecutor's office announces
president Pedro Castillo and accuses him
of leading a criminal organization the
prosecutor claims that the plot is
entrenched in the Government Palace with
the aim of monopolizing controlling and
directing Contracting processes to
obtain illicit profits in total Castile
his wife his sister-in-law and two
nephews were facing a total of six
separate investigations and to influence
peddling irregular Contracting bribery
and even plagiarism among other possible
crimes in short Pedro casio's term as
president has been a lengthy torture
both for himself and for the country as
a whole we were talking about nearly 200
political scandals of all kinds in less
than 500 Days and so visual politic
viewers this is how we arrive on the 7th
of December 2022 on the day which
Castile blew up his presidency but why
did he do it what exactly did it consist
of was it really as so many are
suggested an attempt to carry out a new
socialist revolution in Latin America
and why did this act of institutional
subversion fail well let's find out
[Music]
the non coup d'etat
[Music]
in only 16 months the Peruvian Congress
carried out three presidential vacancy
processes against Pedro Castile
the presidential vacancy which is
something like a vote of no confidence
because the mechanism that the Peruvian
Constitution provides to Congress for
deposing president for a range of
reasons among them moral incapacity
which of course can mean practically
anything in other words the parliament
has a free hand to pursue presidents at
an endless succession of motions of
senshin
[Music]
presidential
situations
Vista English well the fact is that the
first two attempts failed and the third
attempt which was to be voted on on
Wednesday the 7th of December was going
the same way however that same Wednesday
early in the morning something happened
[Music]
the former Chief of Staff for the
ministry of housing salatil marufo
testified before a congressional
investigative committee he stated that
both then housing Minister generir
Alvaro and himself made recurring
payments to both Castile and Castillo's
sister in exchange for keeping their
posts the money allegedly came from Sada
Gorey a real estate businesswoman and
was mainly used to pay bribes and
campaign for the president you know the
ministry of Housing and a real estate
entrepreneur you can join the dots
whether or not this statement is true
the fact is that from this point on
events unfolded rapidly perhaps they
fear that this statement would end up
getting enough votes in Congress to
approve the vacancy proposal who can see
but at 10 46 Castillo's prime minister
Betsy Chavez made an urgent call through
the WhatsApp group that members of the
government shared asking the ministers
to come as soon as possible because this
would be an historic day shortly
thereafter a trembling Castile appeared
on television to announce the political
bombshell
foreign
[Music]
without any constitutional capacity to
do so Castillo announced the dissolution
of Congress the establishment of a
government of exception a curfew and the
reorganization of the justice system it
was what many including the country's
own constitutional Court called an
attempted coup d'etat
is
[Music]
this is important to know contrary to
what has been said Castillo's action had
nothing to do with any kind of socialist
Revolution but his goal was to stay in
power escape the prosecution's
accusations and sidestep the blockade of
Congress he had no constitutional basis
for what he did he found out that in
Congress they already had 87 votes to
vacate him and he mistakenly believed
that the population the armed forces and
the national police were going to
support him and that was not the case
Gustavo adrianzen the former Minister of
Justice at the end of her speech both
the Prime Minister and nine other
members of the cabinet announced their
resignations for their part the
country's main institutions Congress the
Army the police and the Judiciary made
it clear that they would not abide by
the president's plan under any
circumstances
and so barely an hour after proclaiming
the closing of Congress Castillo left
the presidential palace with his family
and his lawyer and former prime minister
at 1 40 PM less than two hours after
giving his speech the Congress
simultaneously missed him and the
president was formally detained Castillo
attempted to reach the Mexican embassy
which was unsuccessful his own
bodyguards by direct order of the police
leadership stopped the van in which the
president was being transported and
proceeded to arrest him
but at this point the question is why
did this observation fail why did it
last barely as long as a couple of
episodes of The West Wing the truth is
that the Peruvian president's strategy
was as incompetent as his government was
nothing new Under the Sun
[Applause]
there was no plan there was no
justification he had no supporters the
majority of his ministers didn't even
know about it absolutely nothing had
been prepared the chief of the joint
command of the Armed Forces genuine
Manuel gourdes De la Torre confirmed the
former president never asked for their
support Castillo was practically alone
unfortunately did not try very hard to
Rally support he was a man absolutely
overwhelmed by events rather than a coup
d'etat you could almost call this like
improvised nonsense it's a sketch of
course at the international level it was
much the same story perhaps the only
exceptions might be Andres Manuel Lopez
obrador and Louis ARCA we consider it
regrettable that due to the interests of
the economic and political Elites since
the beginning of Pedro Castillo's
legitimate presidency an atmosphere of
Confrontation and hostility has been
maintained against him to the point of
leading him to make decisions that have
served his adversaries to consummate his
dismissal with the Sue generis precept
of moral incapacity Andres Manuel Lopez
obrador on Twitter from the beginning
the Peruvian right wing tried to
overthrow a government democratic
elected by the people but the humble
classes who seek more inclusion and
social justice Luis assay president of
Bolivia but wait a minute because this
is not the end of the story Castillo is
guilty but he's not the only guilty
party Peru's problem goes far beyond the
former president check this out
[Music]
the political Titanic that is Peru
after three no confidence processes in
just 16 months and while Pedro Castile
will be prosecuted for rebellion and
perhaps also for conspiracy Peru has a
new president Dinah bulatare Castillo's
vice president resigned after the coup
attempt and was very clear in condemning
her former political partner there has
been an attempted coup d'etat an imprint
promoted by Mr Pedro Castillo which is
not found an echo in the institutions of
democracy or in the street this Congress
of the Republic following the
Constitutional mandate has made a
decision and it is my duty to act
accordingly Dina bulata vice president
of Pedro Castillo and the new president
of Peru the new president has asked
Parliament for a political truce and is
promised to establish a government of
national unity in which all political
forces are represented this has
apparently been well received by the
political groups this is not a time for
ideologies neither of left or right
President boluate we wish you success in
forming a government of national Unity
kaiko fujimori but what can I say it is
almost certain that the new president
will again have practically the same
problem as Castile had including an
investigation for money laundering her
problems may even we end up being worse
because her profile is much more
ideological and much more to the left
[Music]
however Peru's problem was not
exclusively castillos but above all the
persistent political catastrophe the
country is experiencing bulutari as the
sixth president the country has had in
the last five years Congress has
practically refused to work loyally with
any of the country's past presence and
take note because if there is one thing
Congress is doing it is monopolizing
more and more power to the point that
the executive is becoming an irrelevant
player practically a punching bag in
fact one law that was passed in October
2021 had a lot to do with this political
crisis we are talking about law
31355 a lot that basically splits the
balance of power between the government
and the Congress let me explain in Peru
the Congress has the ability to dismiss
the president at the same time the
government has the ability to dissolve
the Congress and call for allegedly of
Elections if the chamber denies the
government's two motions of new
confidence
foreign
however since the approval of law 31355
the power has disappeared in practice
and of course this means that if the
government does not have a parliamentary
majority as is often the case in Peru
where the parliament is almost always
very fragmented and the government's
hands are completely tied it cannot pass
anything and cannot put pressure on the
legislators
the first thing to understand is that
the optional question of confidence the
one requested by the government has been
greatly reduced in practice the
president could never dissolve Congress
ananeira lawyer and professor of
constitutional law at the Universidad
Del Pacifico and guess what the
breakdown in the balance of power is
directly connected with the disaster
that has been the Castillo
Administration Congress has been able to
make life impossible for the government
without the slightest consequence in
other words the checks and balances of
government have disappeared
[Music]
this for example has caused Congress to
sideline almost 70 bills put forward by
the government and perhaps that is why
the disapproval rating of Congress is
almost 90 percent that's quite a record
and to tell the truth it does not bode
well for future governments but keep in
mind this is not only a strictly
political or electoral issue practically
all of Pedro Castillo's predecessors
since the fujimura era have been
prosecuted for corruption shall we take
a look then let's check out
fujimori is in jail for corruption and
crimes against humanity Alan Garcia
ended his life in 2019 while he was
being detained following the operach
Scandal Alexandro todeo is wanted and is
an exile in the United States while he
faces an extradition request oleana
humala is being prosecuted much the same
story and now Castillo an addition with
corruption investigations also faces the
possible crime of rebellion that means
he could be facing many years in prison
in general it's a real disaster politics
and Peru is becoming more and more
unstable and radicalized and obviously
that has consequences it is obvious that
political stability affects investor
confidence it makes them hesitate if
there is no confidence or it's been
undermined then obviously the investment
rate is not going to progress Kurt
Bernier former Peruvian finance minister
at the moment growth expectations for
2023 are being reduced to around 2.5 and
ratings agencies such as Fitch have
recently revised the country's Outlook
from stable to negative the times when
Peru was the engine of Latin America and
a strong candidate for becoming a
regional Powerhouse seemed to be a thing
of the past I'll leave a link in the
description for a video in which scrape
in detail while Peru is getting worse
and worse but now it's over to you what
do you think will happen with the new
Peruvian government how do you rate
Castillo's time in office what do you
think needs to change in his country for
it to become the engine of Latin America
once more leave us your answers in the
comments below and if you've found this
video interesting don't forget to like
And subscribe to all of us here at
visualpolitik if you haven't already
done so all the best and I'll see you
next time
[Music]